my welcome to the circuit of America is
the most amazing racetrack here in
Austin Texas now I'm in a big lover or
stream food roadside food but I'm gonna
do something local
it's called a Frito pie that's right
videos
yes.can mints chopped chilies I'm gonna
make the most amazing memory and put it
back in the bag the way you guys serve
it first off let's get this thing opened
now this is roadsides okay so everything
literally comes out of a can
so how do we judge that up well let me
show you
look at that
unfortunately doesn't look the
advertised does it
don't leave that up in there this would
be good by the way for all camping okay
a staple when you're camping with your
mates over the family off with that
Chili's in
and mix it up gently season
now from the moving out to the ball the
good old sweet Oh now I may look a
little bit rustic bus
by the seasoned them and then from there
beautiful now pay that up once that's
got nice and warm turn down the gas
start your eggs eggs in okay
so then I get beeped aful scrambled
ITEX in this should serve enough
beautiful good bit of butter
do not mix okay the taste
and that tastes like I'm back on scout
camp yeah good old days now that's nice
and warm take that off the heat
okay panel will do the scrambled eggs
okay I've got my little paste it's like
little dip like a French onion dip okay
and then a little cheese you recognize
these cheese bits okay open them up put
that inside the eggs tear that up okay
scrambled egg I'm telling you you can do
a roadside snack elevate it to make it
look tasty scrambled eggs
okay into the pan with some butter
stocking up on that but okay eggs and
cheese in the season yet
from the
we start a scramble race now how cool is
this cooking right inside the pit lane
of this incredible track I've been here
several times it's always the most
exciting Grand Prix in fact we can call
this the pit stop Frito pie now
scramble is coming together we can start
lightly seasoning them such a salt
don't you pepper then she goes
round and round the most expensive
ingredients here
oh my god
discriminates come together
nicely seasoned
take my french dip okay but spoon of
that in there and then from there a
little touch of milk
Tatanka cream and love
now start to come together beautifully
and queuing and check this evening okay
and this
we stopped folding in
I have around beef no hello
in she goes chill a useful
fold that in
it smells like a nice light spicy eggs
cookout for 30 more seconds
just to check the seasoning
hmm
that
I may not look attractive but trust me
it's bloody delicious
now
yes this is how they serve it
in it back
I know any of you outside Texas watching
this will be thinking what is he doing
well let me tell you this
is a staple pull that back
the rest goes in
oh my god then finally
take your topping
and you finish that crunch on top
there you go not a frito pie they may
not look the most amazing snack but
trust me
good luck that
delicious
[Music]